okay I'm gonna get started it is good
okay hello everyone my name is Matthew
Rocklin I worked for anaconda and Hunter
was previous into his continued mana
lytx and then hundreds many things
holding services enterprise software
training we also write open source
software Heather grant funded or just by
good of our hearts and this is about
that so I work on the open source side
of the company more group more research
aside I usually work on a library called
task for parallel confor parallel and
shrewd computing it's not gonna be a
little bit different it's gonna need
about stream processing mostly so I'm
not talking a whole lot about desk it's
mostly gonna be about API so streaming
processing in Python how we might build
those briefly though just to give you
some more context about desk so who here
has heard of desk ok who here has heard
more about maybe das data frame a big
parallel pandas versus you know - delay
- tasks scheduling kinds of things so
pandas people we're not by people and
then task scheduling people way fewer of
those people but actually the tasks of
the people are probably the more common
active users so I'm going to give you a
situation that comes up a lot in my life
so I have here a little task cluster on
my local machine on the Left I have a
Jupiter lab notebook and on the right I
have the dashboard I have a few
functions which do sort of trivial
amounts of work and sleep to simulate
work these might be functions in your
world but you know maybe they're loading
data maybe they're processing data or
maybe they're training models like run
them locally or I can used ask to run
them on a cluster instead now to be
clear a task isn't paralyzing individual
calls of these functions they're just
running them on some core on my on my
remote machine so I've run set of
calling increment locally on one
reducing the value to I can then submit
I guess instead used asked submit that
as a future so the concurrent futures
API its standard in Python 3 a variety
of products implemented and that future
is kind of like a pointer it's pointing
to a remote data somewhere else on my
machine or on other machines I get back
there was loads if I want to go through
this fast don't worry about it this is
just
in context if you haven't no desk now
it's got somewhat lot more useful if you
combined with four loops where I can
submit you hundreds of these tasks per
second and the various scores on my
local computer can crunch on these tasks
in parallel so on the right here you're
seeing all of my cores you know compute
on increment we don't double etc and add
in a few more workers there so this is
on my local machine but you can imagine
it happening on a cluster
maybe I scale up my cluster a little bit
and now I have more computing power so
task has a few API is to do generic
parallel processing and these can be a
fairly time reactive so you can submit
tasks you know separating seabed
thousand tasks wait for the first ten to
arrive look at those results cancel the
rest add more etc TAS is actually quite
flexible so people use it to parallelize
numpy and pandas and those things are
built on top of what I'm showing here
but you know in many companies people
used a square an algorithm research
people use - to paralyze other stuff
this is that other stuff component and
ask is not you know do my big data frame
computation it's I've got a bunch of
things you should run it depends on each
other
please compute those things for me and
we can build a variety of things on top
of that so one of those things wouldn't
close this down now and that's lots of
tasks we're in a sea for a little bit
one of those things that people often
ask me to paralyze is streaming
processing so what do I mean by stream
processing so streaming data there's a
variety of talks on streaming systems
I think of link or beam or Apache spark
or storm streaming data sets are
unbounded meaning they might continue
forever common examples are things like
web server logs as long it will click on
your website you'll get more and more
data you know financial time series you
know the stock markets continue going
they're all so timely we're operating on
them in a streaming way because we want
to react to new events when they happen
maybe where is it in credit card fraud
you notice that a lot of credit card is
doing a lot of activity that's odd we
want to respond to that you know within
seconds or minutes so we reduce the
amount of fraud that happens in the
future
so both handling things an unbounded way
so we can't ask for the sum or the
number of elements in a data set that
number is infinite and also responding
to things in a timely way so as they
occur we want to respond those are the
two things we think about when doing
streaming processing as another example
of that one of my favorite examples of
streaming data is one that you have on
your computer you should never do what
I'm about to do this is a massive
security violation but actually look at
all the packets flowing through my
network router using TCP dump so you
actually see the the source IP and the
source port and destination IP and
destination port along with how many
bytes from the packet etc and if I go to
a website this will actually be fairly
active now what we want to turn this
stream of data into and to some sort of
you know dashboard that we can analyze
better you know some sort of system that
we can look at and feel happy about so I
you know I built a little system to do
this so sort of a weekend project an
afternoon project looks like this here's
that same stream of data coming through
and we know we're doing various
histograms of the source and destination
port and IP the debt the ports often
correspond to services server example
HTTP is on 443 and so all of the time
that I'm say going to a service like
Microsoft our generous hosts for today
that's all coming on HTTP and so I've
selected that here and this is now the
sub selection of all the things that
just have port 443 so this is this is
the goal of my talk to build libraries
that allow people to build systems like
what I just built here streaming that as
streaming network data is one such
example but presumably in organizations
you can think of other examples that are
relevant to your field so this was about
180 lines when I first built it I think
it's now about down to a hundred so
we're making these things easier and
easier to build just using bouquet and a
small library I'm talk about today
called streams so let's stop violating
security issues
okay so you've seen that these slides
are online if you go to my Twitter
account and rockland or see Kayla and
the slides are there and there's links
to the blinds and also notebooks you'll
see so we are reinventing a wheel let us
acknowledge that there are many projects
that are very mature that do streaming
data processing libraries like Apache
flink are very well respected both by
users and by technologists also spark
streaming beam storm these generally
come out of sort of the big data space
and they're very very good at handling
standard case streaming processing
systems that occur commonly when you
managing web logs slightly more complex
systems if you sort of go outside of
what those systems are built for you
might use systems like 0 mq or akka or a
variety of other systems that exist I
also want to point people to reactive X
or the sort of reactive programming
generally which so this is a UI
framework and even though it's not about
data processing so much it still has the
same flavor of reacting to events like
mouse clicks or things like that and
taking events as they occur and so
reactive programming and UI and shooting
processing actually look somewhat
similar then we're talking about today
is sort of a blend of those two so again
we're reinventing a wheel this started
off as an educational project for me to
understand how stream processing systems
worked built it a few times and rebuilt
it sort of now feels pleasant enough to
share with people but that's where you
decide so please I would appreciate
feedback after the talk any time tell me
I'm wasting my time so our library
called streams with a Z and streams is
different from the others and it's it's
pythonic so sorry Lee rare to find a
good streaming data processing system in
Python it's very simple in simple cases
it actually everything want to show you
today runs just in a local thread it's
after the end we just ask it's also a
fairly complex so we can get complex if
you want to be any Graces we'll see you
nicely to things like GP repentance
final disclaimer everything s talk is
experimental api's are subject to change
without notice I get emails from people
years later about YouTube talks
complaining why things don't work so
YouTube people this is for you
don't expect this to work in the next in
the next year that being said there's
also being used in production not
approach but it's being used in active
research so it does work in a nice way
so we'll see a few things I'll talk
about streams core basic streaming
primitives will then marry that
dependence and get a streaming data
frame then we'll marry that to desk and
get streaming distributed pen designer
frames so I'm actually gonna switch out
of slides and go to examples for a bit
is this font legible in the back that's
sort of a yeah okay so let's let's make
a stream
I have made a stream and I can do
something simple like like pushed out it
into that stream that didn't do anything
because that stream is just taking that
data and then sending it up nothing is
actually being attached to that stream
to do any action so let's make some
functions that do some things I can make
a function like Inc function like double
now these are really really simple and
we get more complex as we go along
so let's make a couple of streams stream
map ink and then we'll print
let's also double that but again hasn't
done anything even push any data through
our stream yet let's go ahead and do
that
that's no change at the ten okay so i've
pushed out into the input part of my
stream that number ten was we added one
to it we multiplied it by two we done
printed both results and we got these
results printed to the screen so our
stream looks a little bit like this
pipeline on the one side we push in data
on the right side we do things to that
data and streams is tracking how that
data moves throughout that pipeline
there's a very simple pipeline in
practice they look much more complex so
let's look at something slightly less
simple let's say that I had some data to
some function to create some some JSON
data so this is just random data and it
bruises a string which you know is like
a string you might find coming out of a
some sort of device it's got a name it's
got a value as a time now I'm gonna make
a stream that we're gonna use process
that pet data and we're going to first
parse that so records equals sources dot
map JSON downloads then we might also
maybe make a separate stream of names us
again feeding off of records
[Music]
so now I want to push some data into
that stream and we'll see is that all of
my streams just admitted the the most
recent value they've just so let's do
that a few more times so we have these
three objects source records and names
which are just getting streams of values
and we've shaped how those values look
now I can sit here you know with a for
loop or you know maybe I have some some
system that's running all the time and
pushing new data into that maybe I'm
watching Kafka or something or here I'm
just gonna make a little a synchro
routine it's gonna add data into that
around ten times a second I mean not
have these streams that are that are
processing for us so you know we've got
this this thing names we might make
names mouth lengths so now we'll get a
new stream which is the number of
letters in that name relatively simple
is it relatively simple streams we're
seeing nice integration with Jupiter
here so we're used to seeing you know
single output side of Jupiter like one
plus one it a static result out now all
of our results are themselves dynamic
changing things that evolve over time
okay
map is relatively simple we might want
to do something more complex that
requires some state we might want to for
example sum up all of the X values in
these records so again we can't ask for
the sum of the entire stream because
that's infinite but we can't ask for the
sum the values have you seen so far so
we use sort of the standard binary
operators and reduce trick if you've
seen that they make a make a function
it's a binary operator it takes some
previous total and some new value
there's going to turn those and we'll
take records we will map
of the xvalue and will accumulate this
binary operator with a starting value of
zero again it's just a rolling evolution
so these are the two most simple
operations you could use when when
building up streaming operations
there's no syntactic sugar here but this
allows you to build things in a nice way
here's a more complex accumulator which
is adding up all of the number of times
we see in each name so let's see they'll
briefly again in slide form here is map
map takes in a stream of things and
produces a new stream of things with
that function applied
here's accumulate takes in a stream of
things it takes in a function and some
previous state and it emits out new
things that have that state accumulated
to it it is similar to reduce from that
fill to reduce but it operates in more
of a rolling way for a lot of this you
could use Python iterators right you
could use generator expressions and it
would work oh well that becomes a little
bit messy it's when you start branching
out your streams or joining them becomes
quite difficult to manage I don't how to
pull from other iterators in a
consistent way streams manages that for
you so it's very easy to branch rooms in
many streams we're seeing that here
right we're pushing in only in one part
of the stream but many things are coming
out there many of our plots are updating
or you can dramatically different times
maybe you have data being shoved in your
systems being predicted against some
secular model but actually periodically
you update your secular model so it's
also a stream that's also going to be
changing I'm gonna have that all whole
system updating so you can imagine also
joining system is in various ways the
streams provides an essence to do those
there are many other operations I'm
showing the very simple things also
common when dealing with streaming
systems is dealing with different flow
rates so in this example we have a
couple of streams where the user is
maybe they're you know they're just
shoving that in as fast as they can
maybe at the end of our stream maybe
this is some sort of right to database
operation and maybe that's gonna be a
little bit slower right maybe some sort
of asynchronous system so if that's slow
you might run into a problem where all
of our data builds up at that part of
the pipeline we actually want to tell
our user to slow down this is you're
going too fast
so streams integrates with tornado so as
you're sending data forward in the
stream stream is sending back tornado
futures and you can wait on those
futures until things are happy and done
if you don't know tornado or async
programming that's totally fine the
streams API is intended to work in a
synchronous way as well so you have to
think about this at all streams we'll
handle it for you
you also artificially add things like
rate limiters or buffers maybe you know
some API can only be hit you know a
thousand times an hour maybe you know
that you know this particular spot in
the pipeline is actually very cheap to
have data build up and that's fine so
there's a variety of mechanisms I'm not
gonna go into at all I just wanna
mention that there there there are a
variety of mechanisms that help you
shape the flow of data throughout your
stream these pictures I'm showing are
very very simple traditional streams
that are actually running in practice
tend to be very complex and they have a
variety of things going in and out and
it becomes very very quickly some part
of your system breaks and you want some
ability to to protect those parts of the
system and streams provides those
mechanisms okay trees to extend this is
verbatim I think I chopped off the dock
string but this is verbatim the map
class and streams this is the filter
class
these are simple only because we worked
fairly hard to make them simple you know
I rewrote this thing a few times before
I got to a point where I was happy with
it so streams is there something you
like it's really easy to build your own
if you want to understand time
processing like rate limiting you need
to do a little bit of tornado tornado is
a common frame for concurrent
programming or if you prefer a single
side of things so okay next I'll talk
about data frames so you can imagine
having a stream where all of the
elements passing through that stream
we're not you know dictionaries or lists
but we're themselves pandas data frames
and you might want to build algorithms
on top of those pandas that are for
so for example if I wanted to compute
something like you know some subset only
where the name is Ellis take the X
column compute the sum I can do that
with this map and accumulate functions
okay so I can map over my stream and
select only those data frames only those
rows my data frames for which the name
column is Alice I could make an
accumulator which took off the X column
computed the sum and this would give me
the same semantics the same results so I
sort of wanted to write down two pandas
but would give that to me in a streaming
updatable way so let's go and see that
so let's make some batches so got the
records so I don't want to make a
panda's data frame for every dictionary
passing through my stream that will be
inefficient pandas only works really
well when you have a lot of rows so I'm
going to collect all of those records
that come in and say maybe 300
milliseconds then I'm going to take
those patches I'm going to map lists on
them because pandas data frames a little
bit little finicky there we go so we now
have a stream of pandas data fans and
here's that code that we just saw from
before this lines so here we're
computing the sum of the X column of all
the rows that were named Alice now that
can get kind of tricky especially going
to do more complex operations like group
by operations or windowed systems or
rolling averages that can get difficult
so we built a bunch of these algorithms
for you so there's the streams data
frame system and what this does it takes
in a normal stream of pandas data frames
and it gives you an object that looks
and feels a lot like a panda's data
frame so this object is not a panda's
data frame
it's a streaming data frame but it looks
very similar so again we have this this
desire to compute this
this result here and we did that above
right by making a mapping function
making aggregation function do that now
with the streaming data frame API and
we're gonna do it like this
[Music]
so we're satisfying a good subset of the
pandas API so it's the exact same code
we'd have from pandas it now just works
in a streaming way that began becomes
more valuable when you do one to
something more complex
let's go on a window by five seconds on
a group by the name we want to compute
the mean of the X and y columns if that
works
nope
[Music]
ah that is because this is not a time
series data frame okay hold on
you do one thing I'll fix things DF of
time equals d f dot times type so this
is actually just showing you that a lot
of the pandas API works so I need to
make this index a date time index in
order date time processing like windowed
operations
[Music]
there we go it looks much nicer now I
can add window and support to this data
frame much nicer okay so the system
handles a fair amount of the pandas API
it does window operations group by
operations reductions filters etc well
all of it lots of things the parents can
do this can't do but a fair amount of
can also one of my sort of favorite
features is that it actually by Phillip
burger just this last weekend is that
you can take this exact same command and
you can plot that using again just the
pandas plotting API
let's get so this integrates with
bouquet and hall of use to give you
trimming plots off readout frames again
this is built on sort of the standard
core of the stream system which handles
a variety of piping so all of these
things we've done in the jupiter
notebook aren't what you normally do
with streaming systems normally you
build plots you build system they're
going to trigger to email someone to
trigger some fraud api etc but you can
imagine building those into proper
applications like we saw in the
beginning with that dashboard with
network data all the things that we
built here all the different things that
are plotting out data for us that's
depicted here and this in this plot so
each each little circle at the end here
is probably resulting in some jupiter
Acela being updated whenever we pushed
out it in here at the beginning i'm
streams isn't managing all of that
administrative administrative software
okay it's kinda slides
[Music]
okay so we've seen that you could do
these sorts of things with map and
accumulate with streams core and streams
data frame is just syntactic sugar on
top of that just to give you a panda's
like experience in a nice way
you can do more complex things which is
pleasant you can also do it give you
nice things like plotting this plotting
is using the bouquet library for active
plots hall of use to do all of the the
nice shaping of those plots and this is
added by Philip rota ger I got this
weekend so many thanks to him
so saw this integrates nicely with
Jupiter notebook is using standard
Jupiter notebooks ipython widgets which
I'd recommend people use they're very
very productive if you want to make nice
interactive things in notebooks this is
not that hard this is literally adding
the alive updates for these with
something like 10 to 20 lines of code
they're not saying that streams is cool
I'm saying that ipython widgets are cool
and you should consider using them same
with bouken okay so we've spoken a bit
about misspelled data frames smoking a
bit about streaming systems and data
frames and all of that was happening on
a single core on my laptop in my Jupiter
notebook session I didn't set anything
up there was no extra service I was
connecting to theirs happening in Python
locally it's not scalable but you can
process you know gigabytes per second
with a single thread on your computer so
if you are careful about things that can
be enough for you one of my goals with
streams was to make it simple in simple
cases and so you don't even know tornado
you just need to do basic operations and
you can handle a fair amount of
computation that being said my job is to
make Python scale well let's let's look
at desc
so again task is known for things like
paralyzing an umpire paralyzing pandas
paralyzing parts of scikit-learn
concurrent futures like what we saw
before but dasa is more commonly used in
production for paralyzing other stuff so
research groups or industry or
enterprise have their own system inside
of their company they want to paralyze
and they throw a lot of frame stuff they
throw an umpire stuff and they just used
the engine that's powering that and ask
has been
very commonly used to power other stuff
so the question arises can it power the
streams library that we just built right
answer is yes there is a stream stop
task module which gains a task stream
object which is more or less a drop-in
replacement for the normal stream object
so anything I guess everything I just
showed where it's just fine with desk
with some caveats task is very nice user
nor a single machine just to use all of
your course it's very lightweight it
also scales out to thousands of machines
if you wanted to the task streams bit
was very easy to write we based on top
of the concrete futures module and it
took around two hundred lines of code to
do map and accumulate and some other
things okay so if you have an existing
stream like like this guy you can use
the desk stream in addition by creating
a client and then just introducing
scatter and gather calls at appropriate
places so on a line a - we are deciding
to parse this data locally then we
scatter that out to the cluster so the
cluster scores are not going to be using
that there's made us be our local course
and that'll be doing a lot of processing
after that oops and I want to go local
we call gather and this brings us back
from a task stream back to local stream
so you can mix and match going out to
the cluster coming back in a fairly easy
way and your code does have to change a
lot so let's go look at an example so
I'm gonna make a tiny dash cluster I'm a
laptop this is running with with threads
locally and I'm going to create a just
random source of the time series data
when - starts up a starts of this nice
dashboard and so this data is creating
every one milliseconds is making a new
penneth data frame with about about 20
rows and so each bar you see here on the
right is one of our threads was asked to
compute that random data frame and it's
living on that on that core wherever it
is
now let's go look at that data and so
now you know Dax has to do more work has
to pick off the tail off data has to
accumulate some things so you see
there's more things happening here on
the right and we can do you know some
our aggregations and and ask will again
you know pick up some more and more work
it looks like there's a fair amount
happening here but actually these
computations are relatively fast so if
you zoom in there's actually a lot a lot
of white space so this is not at all
stressing stressing our system and you
can do all the nice things we did before
like time series plots
so you're rolling averages over time
that's nice it's relatively snappy -
just add a little bit of latency onto
these things but it's nice and it's
running the exact same code now using
many pores my laptop and it would be
trivial to extend us on to a cluster
literally I would just change the
address here at the top that I would
morning I'm running on so I would type
in you know some some scheduler address
that's what I need to do to run this and
set on a cluster instead of on my local
machine so that is the extents of the
desk talk within this talk everything
more or less just works reimplemented
api and we have them the same api with
tasks and it wasn't that hard okay so
performance is interesting i care a lot
about performance streams ads overhead
right using a simple Python for loop is
much faster using streams it's something
like 10 to 100 times fast in the streets
so why that iterators have sort of a you
know ten hundred and a second overhead
you can do you know many millions of
things in Python in a seconds streams
has heard of a microsecond - 10 micro
say no bread so you can do you know
hundreds of thousands to millions of
things per second to quit streams that's
still relatively fast compared to many
things but it might be slow relative to
what you're doing compared the
stupendous making a panda's data frame
takes you know something like a
millisecond so using streams data frames
you know all of your operations should
certainly take longer than a millisecond
otherwise pandas will slow you down
tasks adds an additional overhead of
something like 200 microseconds per core
so if you're trying to saturate say
hundred cores your task should take
someone the vicinity of 20 milliseconds
to be of any use so there's certainly
some some loss of performance as you
scale but that is still relatively small
and all those numbers are well below
human response times so if you are
making dashboards everything in this
stack is relatively relatively snappy
interestingly so if you're to look at
what's slowing things down here in these
plots but if you notice but I was
running through my notebook things are
getting a little bit more sluggish it's
actually the jupiter notebook in many
cases if you a few benchmark things
changing 20 notebook cells every you
know 10 or 20 Hertz is actually somewhat
hard on the juban notebook protocol we
haven't that's probably on my own note
on their end but I was apply some things
we can find we can optimize their okay
what doesn't work so yeah this is very
new
this is nights weekends project for the
last few months maybe we be start being
a more bigger thing now so convenient
data source integration there's some
Kafka support not a whole lot I've
played a thathe very easy on my own but
it's sort of not in a nice Pleasant way
out of order data frame handling for
time there's really no benchmarking or
profiling there's other sort of issues
that happen mostly why I'm here not
talking about Gatsby talking about this
so I would love for you guys to try this
out and raise issues and maybe you know
contribute or maybe just say that it's
good or useful in certain domains or not
useful in certain domains that'd be very
helpful so this is my plea to you all to
engage this is a very young project
there's a lot of very low hanging fruit
to do in this project so if you want to
become active as a developer it's a
great way to start it's much usually
like say contributing to numpy which is
very very solidified this is very young
it's very pleasant to work on and that's
it yeah any questions
are we roving mics are just repeating
questions whoever is repeating questions
question in the back
yeah this the domain of this project is
certainly of interest to many enterprise
companies and so that is something that
anaconda cares about that makes that I
can't speak friend of content supporting
this project serious in the future if
you work for a company and you really
need stripping processing and you talk
to anaconda saying hey that few things
really cool then the answer might be yes
but it depends on you all again so this
is very mature grounds our project
yeah solution is how does scattering
gather work with back pressure when you
actually distribute streams so how
scatter works is it's just using the
desk a scatter mechanism so if you have
a client and you scatter something out
that goes to whatever worker it thinks
is a good worker at the time and ask is
clever about that thinking process one
thing at the time so you should probably
think about the granularity of what
you're scattering before you scatter it
you don't want to be scattering a stream
that has millions of things running
through the second you want to do some
sort of aggregation ahead of time yeah
you know ideally you would scatter file
names something that's small but leads
to a big thing or you would scatter you
know ranges in a Kafka queue that's a a
the the offsets thousand to ten thousand
a thousand two one thousand those should
be sent to this worker do some work on
it gathering is the same thing
eventually those things are moving
around our task futures and when you
gather those there's coming back to you
they're just pulling client gather on
them there are things in streams to
control the ordering as you care so you
can again I said there's a lot of things
to shape time and shape flow control and
you can shape ordering as well yeah good
question
that guy uses desk obviously in the task
scheduling way other questions
oh my gosh there
the question is how does scatter and
gather affect the visualization yeah so
when you visualize to have other thing
up here yeah so this is the desk
dashboard on the right and it has a
variety of things going on in it so you
would see things here like you know the
bytes stored on every worker or you know
the kind of things that are in memory
over time you might also see you have
the amount of memory increase on those
workers as things arrive this is showing
the system monitor of all of the task
scheduler this is showing you a
distributed profile of the desk worker
that shows up we'll see
so tasks generally does give you
feedback about when things do scatter
but it's not gonna doesn't show up in
this original plot if that's your
question
we're sure there
which is how I run this production
setting against streams have millions of
events the answer is no I have not the
there are two active use cases that I
know about one is Brookhaven National
Labs
so the keynote this morning was a
research group working in exactly of
that same space who's using streams to
do a lot of image processing I think
there's more of a research group than
like what the entire lab is running on
so it's small there's also some finance
people running on it I think again as a
small research thing I don't can't see
who they are but but no I have not
person done this at scale at all but I
would love for you to do that those
another question over here somewhere
yeah how do I compare these two
contemporary shooting frameworks
lifelink in fact if link sparks framing
and Apache beam those are all way more
mature and and way more solid than this
first of all things where you might
prefer this over that this is lighter
weight its pythonic beam has a Python
API sort of spark streaming as a Python
a that mostly just leads to to Java this
also I believe although please correct
me if I'm wrong the amount of control
you have here at a finer level is some
is slightly more than what you'll find
out of something like flink or being or
spark streaming this is somewhere in
between the Flinx space and like the 0
mq space but again if you're actually
building something in production today
do not use this you should use flink or
spark streaming or beam
yeah question is gonna replace all of my
panis outer frame code with streams out
of frame code and will it still work the
answer is no because Panther your pen is
your panis code and variably contains
some small corner the Canada's API that
this is not support this supports a
common subset but everybody uses pandas
using it in a very different way
civilian so our experience with task
data frames which do support a very
broad set subset dependence that is it
has been a long time to build up all of
it API and discover what everyone uses
this implements a very very small small
subset okay yep
yeah question is have I done this when
they serve online learning like with
partial Fitz
yeah partial so the answer is no but you
could and a partial fit is very much
falls into this very nice layer it's
very much accumulative function that
being said online learning is a tricky
subject you should be aware of how
you're mixing data what you're holding
on to so you need to know about machine
learning to do that well but streams
could certainly be a tool to help you do
that okay once twice sold
thank you off your time I'll be around
[Applause]